bonjour à toutes et à tous une vidéo
pour vous présenter le site de la banque
mondiale qui vous permettra de collecter
les informations nécessaires à la
réalisation de votre travail
alors tout d'abord rendez vous sur
google vous tapez simplement banque
mondiale la première proposition
c'est donc mondial c'est une association
intergouvernementale en fait la banque
mondiale et cet organisme collecte
beaucoup de données qui vont nous être
utile en géographie et en formation et
géographique et sociale donc quand vous
allez sur le site de banque mondiale
vous de cliquer sur l'onglet données
puisque vous recherchez des données
alors n'ayez pas crainte du temps
d'attentes
parfois certains certains tableaux de la
banque mondiale sont assez long à
charger parce qu'il ya pas mal de
données donc ça va dépendre de votre
collection évidemment vous arrivez sur
la page les données ouvertes de la
banque mondiale et là vous avez
directement le choix ici entre naviguer
par pays ou par indicateurs ici vous
votre travail c'est par rapport à un
pays dont vous avez cliqué bien sûr sur
pays
vous allez avoir un premier tri comme ça
qui est fait quand vous arrivez sur
cette nouvelle page
vous avez tous les pays qui sont passés
par un alphabet tic est assez facile
vous avez aussi dans l'encart de droite
les différentes régions imaginons vous
vouliez travailler sur amérique du nord
vous avez toutes les données qui sont
qui sont agrégés imaginons que le pays
sur lequel du travail et soient
l'afrique du sud vous quittez donc sur
afrique du sud
là je ne vous apprends rien vous avez un
premier une première page qui va vous
proposer toute une série d'indicateurs
alors ça vous donne déjà une bonne idée
seulement vous n'allez pas vous baser là
dessus parce que ça va être relativement
apprécié vous allez plutôt aller dans le
détail est ici vous devez aller dans le
deuxième onglet
droite khattab banque de données la page
sa fiche est composé de deux parties la
partie de gauche vous permet de
sélectionner tout est donné et la partie
droite aperçu vous permet de visualiser
ces mêmes données
vous n'avez pas modifié le premier le
premier rencard base de données vous
gardez ce qui est sélectionné par train
d'aller plus loin
le pays vous avez déjà sélectionné votre
pays
dans le cas qui nous occupe l'afrique du
sud donc vous n'avez pas à modifier si
vous deviez un séparément travailler sur
un autre pays bas vous ouvrez l'onglet
et vous allez modifier vos différentes
informations
vous avez dit ça il ya toujours un temps
de chargement
parce que comme la base de données et
d'immenses ça prend du temps de ici
voilà vous avez les différents pays qui
apparaissent vous pourriez sélectionné
deux pays par exemple pour comparer mais
nous devons travailler normalement vous
n'aurez pas besoin de faire ça les
séries ça ce sont les variables que vous
allez étudier les différents indicateurs
donc ça vous allez devoir ouvrir cet
angle est là et vous allez devoir aussi
ouvrir l'onglet anglais times
quels sont les années que vous allez
vouloir étudier une autre rupture dans
le travail vous devez quand même
travaillé sur quelques années donc ça va
vous précisez peut-être 1990 2000 et
2010 par exemple ça c'est vous qui
choisissez le nombre d'années sur lequel
vous travaillez mais ça va vous
permettre de voir l'évolution évidemment
du développement ou du non développement
nous avait lésé nombre d'éléments qui
sont sélectionnés je vais aller
directement ouvrir l'onglet série vous
allez comprendre le principe et vous
suffira dans sept ans et on glisse et de
cocher ce qui vous intéresse
quels sont les indicateurs que vous
allez choisir pour parler du
développement de votre pays pour
toujours ce temps d'attentes
je sais que les jeunes comme vous
parfois son fort un patient à ce niveau
là haut niveau
la tente des connexions et de
l'actualisation des pages mais ici
malheureusement ça sera toujours comme
ça quoi donc voilà ici voyez par exemple
combien de pourcentage la population a
accès à l'électricité
[Musique]
combien même chose en anglais combien
achats d'actions transition des choses
que vous comprendrez pas forcément comme
celle ci par exemple moi je vous demande
pas de comprendre vous allez juste
sélectionné les choses qui vous semble
plus pertinente pour parler du
développement
là le début de l'école primaire en année
voyez il ya des choses c'est assez alors
vous avez parfois sélectionner des
données et parfois il y aurait il n'y
aura rien il faudra revenir sur cet
onglet bombay a sélectionné moi ce que
je vous propose c'est d'utiliser aussi
ce petit ce petit filtre qui vous permet
de trier les données par un parent par
thème et vous avez ici aussi un outil
qui vous permet de tous des sélectionnés
donc voilà je vais faire le tri il y
aura plus de données sélectionnées par
exemple je vais lui demander
je retourne au début j'avais vu quelque
chose intéressante avec un accès ou là
le nombre d'abonnés à la téléphonie
mobile je pourrais me dire mais tient si
j'ai beaucoup de gens qui sont qui ont
un forfait mobile c'est parce que voilà
ils ont un certain niveau de
développement
donc je le sélectionne une fois que vous
avez fait votre petit marché dans ces
données vous appliquer les modifications
de publier de faire ça et vous voyez le
tableau de droite va être mise à jour il
y aura plus qu'une seule donnée qui sera
évidemment abonnés à la téléphonie
mobile
voilà nous vous voyez que en afrique du
sud
j'ai maintenant réduire la la partie de
gauche qui ne m'intéresse plus
maintenant je sais pas la réduire plus
j'ai maintenant le nombre d'abonnés de
téléphonie mobile qui en afrique du sud
nous je vois l'évolution donc là vous
pouvez maintenant vraiment voir si votre
pays se développe ou s'il se développe
pas ce qui est très pratique vous pouvez
directement transformer ces données pour
la session expiré mais vous pouvez
transformer cette donnée en en graphique
vous cliquerez simplement ici vous allez
voir vos données qui sont transformant
graphique est ici dans option de
téléchargement si vous faites excellent
une csv vous allez télécharger les
données sur votre ordinateur
donc je vais télécharger les données je
clique hymne le charge
je pense qu'ils me les a chargés la
fenêtre va s'ouvrir pour le
téléchargement vous l'enregistrer sur
votre ordinateur
et à partir de ce moment là vous pouvez
travailler et donner comme vous le
souhaitez je ne réponds pas en excès nos
pays si je ne sais pas à quoi c'est dû
mais ça ça sera l'objet de toutes façons
d'une prochaine vidéo comment utiliser
les données qui ont été téléchargées
dans un tableur excel csv vous pouvez
éventuellement utilisés
google est là google chine tout ce qui
fonctionne très bien j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a aidé à y voir plus clair
avec ce site de la banque mondiale qui
va être une ressource essentielle pour
votre travail de formation géographiques
et sociales à très bientôt